Will Trump in
Fulton County,
prosecutors have agreed on a $200,000
cash bond
just ahead
of his expected surrender
at the Fulton County Jail on Thursday.
We're now told it will be Thursday.
Brian Todd is taking a closer
look into this into this jail for us.
What can you tell us
about the former president
as co-defendants
when they actually show up there
what they can expect?
Wolf, according to the Fulton County
sheriff, is to be treated
like any other defendant at that jail.
But we do have new information tonight
on how the process
could be streamlined
for Donald Trump
and the other defendants.
Donald Trump,
Rudy Giuliani
and 17 other defendants
this week are expected
to be formally booked
at the Fulton County Jail,
also known as Rice Street, a hulking
crumbling structure
that's garnered a notorious reputation.
The sheriff of Fulton County
insisting that despite their high
profiles, Trump
and the others will be treated
like every other defendant
booked at this jail.
If you're indicted,
then we're going to treat you
as though you indicted here locally.
And so we will continue to
do fingerprints, mug shots, etc.
What might it look like inside when Trump
and the others formally surrender?
Retired Fulton County Sheriff's
Lieutenant Charles
Rambo says normally people
who are surrendering
come through the facility's
front door first.
But regardless of which entrances Trump
and the others arrive in.
They would be pat down,
led to the booking office in the rear.
From there,
they probably will have to have ties
and shoestrings
and all those type of things taken.
Then from there, the persons would be
fingerprinted, given a booking photo.
Donald Trump
and the other defendants are expected
to be photographed
for mug shots,
but it's unclear when those pictures
will be made public.
People familiar with the process tell
CNN normally those booked at
this jail are searched thoroughly
by a jail deputy,
and at some point,
given a medical examination
and a pretrial screening
to determine
if they can sign out
on their own recognizance.
But it's not clear
if Trump or the other high
profile defendants in this case
will go through those steps.
For a normal defendant,
it would take hours to go
through those procedures.
But with these defendants,
I don't expect Trump
to spend hours in this jail,
because the longer he is
I mean, it's a pain.
It's going to be a hassle for the entire
sheriff's department,
or at least those that are at the jail
when the president
is there going to be a circus?
If they didn't have bond agreements?
Donald Trump
and the other defendants
might have been held in custody at this
jail,
which observers
say could be a nightmarish experience.
The rice free
jail is not a pleasant place.
It's dirty It's scary.
Last month,
the Justice Department
launched a civil rights investigation
into the Fulton County Jail
following multiple deaths
inside the facility
last year,
inmate Lashaun Thompson
was found dead in his cell.
His family says unsanitary conditions,
including insect and lice infestation,
contributed to his death.
Even the sheriff agree
it was deplorable conditions like
a third world country.
Three officials of the
Fulton County Jail stepped down
earlier this year
after a preliminary investigation
into Lashaun Thompson's death.
Sheriff Patrick Labonte acknowledges
the poor conditions there.
He says he welcomes
the Justice Department investigation
and he has sought
more than $2 billion in county
funding to build a new jail Wolf.
Horrendous situation over there.
Thanks very much, Brian Todd reporting
I want to bring in
CNN legal
analyst Norm Eisen for more on
the breaking news we're following.
The breaking news
that the former president, Donald Trump,
will turn himself in
to authorities down in Georgia
on Thursday.
What's your reaction to him?
Well, Wolf,
despite the fact
that we've seen this before,
there is no denying
the historic nature of it
even to have one
surrender one time by a president.
Now, the fourth time
These are some of the most
serious charges
he faces
with some of the most serious penalties.
But we also have to be
cognizant, Wolf, of the ways
in which the former president
is utilizing the spectacle
of these surrenders
and the related
appearances, the arrangements
to drive his support
and his popularity in the Republican
presidential primaries.
So we're seeing that
and we can expect that as well.
On Thursday,
if he were just a regular citizen
and he was facing these
criminal charges,
he'd not only be fingerprinted,
but have a mug shot.
But presumably,
they could deny him even bail.
Right.
They could.
I think most regular citizens who were
who had no history of conviction,
he has multiple criminal charges,
but he has not been convicted,
would be eligible either for bail
or for a bond of the kind
that he's posting here.
We know that also from the treatment
of his co-defendants.
But we do expect that
some of the usual strictures
in this jail, which is not a
very nice place to be.
Some of the usual strictures
will be relaxed to move him
in and out quickly.
We've seen that in the prior arrest,
the prior surrenders.
And we'll see that here, too.
And, of course,
the Secret Service is negotiating that.
That is a security concern.
So for that reason alone,
because he'll have
a strong accompaniment, strong security,
he'll have a very different
experience than the normal defendant.